THAT SAID THAT HE WILL -- THAT
COMEY WAS NOT TELLING THE TRUTH
ABOUT SEVERAL OF THE MORE ABSURD
THINKS HE SAID LAST NIGHT.
JOINING US NOW, THE ONE AND
ONLY, CARTER PAGE.
CARTER, IT IS GOOD TO SEE YOU.
FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO PLAY, IF
YOU DON'T MIND, BEFORE WE GET
INTO YOUR FILING, WHAT WAS SAID
ABOUT YOU IN THIS INTERVIEW.
FIRST OF ALL, THE FULL SCREEN,
SO WE CAN READ IT.
STEPHANOPOULOS SAID, YOU ALSO
HAD YOUR EYE ON CARTER PAGE.
HE HAD ALSO BEEN WORKING WITH
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
COMEY SAYS, CORRECT,
STEPHANOPOULOS SAYS, WHAT WAS
YOUR CONCERN THERE?
THEN COMEY,  SAYS, WAS HE IN ANY
WAY COORDINATING WITH THE
RUSSIANS AS AN EFFORT TO
INFLUENCE OUR ELECTIONS?
WE HEAR THE WORD COLLUSION ALL
THE TIME.
COLLUSION IS NOT A WORD THAT IS
FAMILIAR TO ME FROM MY WORK.
COMEY CONTINUES AND SAYS, IF   I
COMEY CONTINUES AND SAYS, IF   S
ANYBODY CONSPIRING, HELPING THE
RUSSIANS ACCOMPLISH THEIR GOAL
OF INTERVIEWING AND THE AMERICAN
ELECTIONS, THAT IS WHAT THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION WAS ALL ABOUT.
CARTER, YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> I ACTUALLY LOVE THAT QUOTE.
I FORGET, IT WAS A VERY LONG
SERIES OF WORDS THERE.
CONSPIRING, AIDING, ABETTING.
THAT IS A PERFECT DESCRIPTION OF
WHAT THE STEELE DOSSIER WAS
DOING ON BEHALF OF THE DNC AND
THE DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE THAT
YEAR.
IT'S ACTUALLY A PERFECT -- WHAT
VARIOUS PEOPLE WERE DOING IN
WASHINGTON, AGAIN, IT'S EARLY,
WE DON'T KNOW THE FULL DETAILS.
BUT THAT BASICALLY SUMS IT ALL
UP.
>> Laura: SO, CARTER, WHAT
HAPPENED IN FEDERAL COURTS
TODAY?
WHAT IS YOUR FILING ATTEMPTING
TO SHOW ON WHAT YOU CLAIM IT
WILL PROVE ULTIMATELY?
>> LAURA, IT'S A REQUEST OR A
ROAD MAP FOR WHAT I AM PLANNING
TO PUT OUT THERE IN TERMS OF MY
AMENDED COMPLAINT.
I FILED A COMPLAINT LAST
SEPTEMBER AND I PLAN TO DO AN
UPDATE THAT COMPLAINT.
IT IS INTERESTING, BECAUSE
EVERYTHING -- IT WAS AN HONOR TO
SPEAK AFTER THE THREE FBI,
FORMER FBI OFFICIALS.
EVERYTHING THEY ARE SAYING ABOUT
RESTORING THE DIGNITY AND KIND
OF LOOKING OUT FOR THE DIGNITY
OF THE FBI, THEY REFLECT THE
PEOPLE -- I NEVER MET MR. COMEY.
THEY WERE THE TYPE OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE JUST ON
BEFORE ME THAT REALLY REPRESENTS
EXACTLY WHAT I AM USED TO
DEALING WITH, IN TERMS OF ALL OF
MY INTERACTIONS, BOTH AT THE
FBI, BUT ALSO CIA AND OTHER
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES.
YOU KNOW, I HOPE, IN ORDER TO DO
THAT, WHAT THEY NEED TO DO IS,
IN TERMS OF THE RESTORATION OF
THE DIGNITY OF THE FBI, IS TO
RELEASE ALL OF THE FISA WARRANT
APPLICATIONS, TO GET ALL THE
RIGHT INFO OUT THERE, AS TO WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
>> Laura: WERE YOU SURPRISED,
CARTER?
WERE YOU SURPRISED WHEN
JIM COMEY BRUSHED OFF THE
QUESTION ABOUT WHY HE DIDN'T
INFORM THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
FIRST MEETING WITH THE
THAT NATIONAL SECURITY BRIEF?
HE DIDN'T REVEAL THAT THE
DOSSIER WAS FUNDED BY HILLARY?
HE KIND OF SET, THAT WASN'T MY
GOAL, THAT WASN'T NECESSARY TO
AFFECT MY GOAL.
WERE YOU SURPRISED ABOUT THAT?
>> IT IS JUST SO LATE LADEN
>> IT IS JUST SO LATE LADEW
>> IT IS JUST SO LATE LADET
>> IT IS JUST SO LATE LADEH
>> IT IS JUST SO LATE LADES
>> IT IS JUST SO LATE LADEO
MANY POLITICAL MOTIVES.
I THINK THAT IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
I THINK PART OF THAT QUOTE, I
FORGET THE EXACT TERMS ARE USED,
I'M NOT SURE WHETHER I USED THE
TERM STEELE DOSSIER.
I WONDER IF HE USED THE TERM
DODGY DOSSIER BECAUSE THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT IT WAS.
IT IS SO BEYOND ANY COMMON
SENSE.
WHAT'S INTERESTING, OVER THE
LAST 24 HOURS, WEEK OR SO AS
THIS HAS SORT OF BECOME THE BIG
NEWS ITEM, I WAS ALWAYS
WONDERING, HOW COME I NEVER GOT
GOT -- OUT FROM THE FBI NEVER
REACHED OUT TO ME AFTER I SENT
THEM A LETTER IN SEPTEMBER OF
2016, OFFERING TO TALK TO THEM?
YOU KNOW, THESE SAFETY --
>> Laura: I DON'T MEAN TO
INTERRUPT BUT EVERYONE SHOULD
UNDERSTAND THAT NOT ONLY DID YOU
OFFERED TO SPEAK TO THEM, THEN
YOU DID SPEAK, I BELIEVE THE
CONGRESS, AND MARCH OF 2017, OR
YOU DID SPEAK TO THE DOJ AND
MARCH OF 2017, AND THEN THEY
CONTINUED TO APPLY FOR ANOTHER
FISA EXTENSION.
CORRECT?
AND MY STATING THAT CORRECTLY?
AFTER YOU ALREADY MET WITH THEM?
>> IT WILL BE INTERESTING, WHEN
ALL OF THIS RIDICULOUSNESS IS
COMPLETELY OUT THERE.
RANK ORDER THE MOST
RIDICULOUSNESS OF THE FOUR.
I USED TO THINK THE ORIGINAL
ONE, AFTER THE WORLD PREMIERE OF
THE DODGY DOSSIER CAME OUT IN
OCTOBER --
>> Laura: EACH ONE GETS WORSE
THAN THE NEXT, CARTER.
BECAUSE IN EACH SUCCESSIVE
APPLICATION FOR THE FISA